all right I'm recording now how's it
going
thanks yeah it sounds like you know
they've already been underway for a
while so that's why you're back here and
this kind of take it easy back here I
felt like it hurt just sitting and
watching them oh well that's kind of
what I get yeah guys are so fun you know
that's it that's all whoa yeah but
that's just kind of like how was I at
the convention like you know some people
just like stand by and like this look
ask you a question like every like 10
minutes yeah yeah I was like you could
talk to us you don't have to just stare
like there's some people that like I'm
good yeah that was funny yeah hey yeah
cuz that's how you know some people are
just like I just want to look yeah I
want to talk it's like I just want to
admire your presence let me go see what
I can catch him there
I'll see gift I think we should keep
that around there just for comedic
effect but yeah adding having more
knickknacks and whatnot just adds the
illusion but I think it's the turban or
wherever the hell that is that makes the
look yeah but it was like a fancy chefs
net yeah but I don't know how much more
be here we can take that it airs yeah
the turban on yeah have you just pull
your ear levy around
yeah can you pull it yeah it's just so
much oh hi let me tell you your your
chose you are looking so beautiful it's
sexy today
ah okay wait for makeup are we done
doing let me tell you about your sex
life huh are you yeah no that looks good
okay my Spoony always looks good I
remember that like you mentioned that
before yeah Brad you psychic porno
direct yeah just called them as we
remember sorry but yeah we were sitting
at the booth at the convention what the
hell got us started on that it was just
something over you guys is table knows I
was at your table and so we got started
that you were psychic I was like we need
to make Dennis to come bring a psychic
oh it was Oh
we were making fun of the picture that
Ryan used on the back of the paranoia oh
yeah where you're just like it's like it
makes me look like psychic like where
the word of your
oh that was like I see that did you look
at the trailer that I sent you for
fucking wired um wouldn't remember last
week is that you here's the tub oh I saw
your review I didn't send the trailer
oh no wait maybe I did see the trailer
actually I did see it yeah oh my god
that review was priceless
the funny thing is like that review
actually just wasn't that funny
just cuz there was nothing you could say
to it I was just like here's just the
horror yeah we all occasionally it like
I had it this is the better this way act
crazy that's the way it was presented a
fucked up dream dressing rooms oh you're
like this way I can make any sense
Scarlett Jo how about that hair please
to God there was a scene at Woodward
Widow like with yeah where Woodward any
angel cross past that way he could just
skip the B story visually oh yeah well I
was waiting for it yeah Bob Woodward
wakes up just like oh Jesus Christ
that would've ni would have been like
okay maybe this movie's alright yeah
that's the only way I make sense like
okay this is Bob Woodward scream how I
love these writing this book oh wait I'm
not surprised I gotta take a break from
this project like cuz I was watching
them one day you're like this is just
like a bad dream I'm like yeah like I
could play it as mine can find Bob I
don't know I've been writing about death
yeah and like they're making a movie
about it like I could see having
fucked-up dreams like that after
drinking too much nyquil it's so bizarre
just oblivious a cold and a fever drink
drinks a nyquil as he's read book and
then he just wakes up like oh shoot it's
a Robert Redford yeah it's not even JT
Walsh it's Robert Redford look I just
love the story that Dan Aykroyd got JT
Walsh fired from loose cannons because
he was in Wired and I was like if you
wanted to punish him you should have
made him stay and loose goodness I
completely agree
the solution crushers ever and it's just
sad that it's in that movie yeah because
I'm like he's everything is fucking
brains and yeah and like Chiklis is
amazing in this yeah like if you seen
this movie no not this fired fired
oh god it was a horse movies you ever
see yeah it's like seriously the most
tasteless biography ever made oh man Oh
John Belushi and it's like insane like
there's some angel talking to Belushi
they try to get Belushi's coffin onto an
airplane you can't fit it so they hold
his body out put it in a body bag
oh she built it into yeah oh my god it's
up and jumps out of here honey you're
looking better you get in the tank I saw
you walking I like that I'm like I'm not
even an Imagine script it's not even in
the script I found myself I don't know
about this you you it's it's drag fellow
shooting no that's uh that's great okay
oh go really good we have mostly Blackie
in the background so no work really well
it's not easel number yes there was no
point you assume that's just like I want
to see smooth your father is even no he
just likes to drink the blood of
Catholic nuns he was mean to your mother
what man wouldn't disembowel his wife
for spilling the sugar you like to watch
Pawn Stars that is a lie it's so
obviously scripted nobody can be as
stupid as Chumlee
you're a fraud a fraud Simba's now sits
down it's getting worse
I just bent the neck of a prostitute no
one seemed to notice was it a zombie
prostitutes what is up with everybody
I'm just saying
great oh I'm this one I say yes that
throws it right no no
hello thoughts is fine oh I serve the
cards ya know Lyle I keep it a cars but
if you want put one on the skull that
okay first one you have to actually
place that after that you can do
whatever you gotta throw one you can put
it there you can do whatever but the
first one yeah you have to play that
place down look at it okay all right
quiet on the set
no more how do you know quite on the set
and action
your father is even is it did they
remake it or is this the 2005 doesn't
okay any even watch this movie series
I never seen yeah I've seen it I can't
believe that people guessed it by you
saying that it was a vampire movie huh I
did nothing but if somebody said blood
rain is abhorrent I just clicked like oh
yeah I felt the same way I'm like how
silly well yeah there's so many vampire
what was eliminating a lot of them cuz
it was like nobody's got it yet and they
did list of time so I'm us by process of
elimination yeah it was really low down
yeah it's such a random one yeah it's
not very memorable in my mind but we
have against the master the bowl yeah
Malcolm I don't know mmm-hmm there's a
British accent listen yeah she's British
I don't even remember I remember there's
some fortune teller scene that didn't
make any sense the whole movie basically
is like and like you can sympathize with
this it's like the editors tray ah like
where you just dump all of your raw
footage and it's out of order
only nobody edited it together it's just
like still out of order like when I
watch movie I'm like there's no rhyme or
reason to wear any of these scenes go
huh I guess they were trying to tell a
nonlinear story but they just messed it
up so that's not working
that's what's not like me I do not care
I give you another pain on it it's just
more like of regal person yeah
you mid-atlantic yeah movie idea cereal
carrot whoops
Jennifer problem or just watch this yes
sure you and bun to now only organics
tied ready Tamara Jackson your father is
evil no he just likes to drink the blood
of Catholic nuns he was mean to your
father mother what man wouldn't
disembowel is wife for spilling the
sugar you like to watch Pawn Stars that
is a lie it is to obviously scripted who
could be as stupid as Chumlee you are
fraud Oh God just know it's getting
worse I Spit the neck of a prostitute no
one seems to notice
was it a zombie prostitute what the hell
is wrong with everyone
great great no no one yeah uh Tara those
great - oh yeah sorry
disgusting I'm a bad killer
Gwen Lissette ready Tamil yes
your father is evil it's getting worse
I just spit the neck of a prostitute and
no one seems to notice
was it a zombie prostitute what the hell
is wrong with everyone
try a woman you can still sit there just
the last line just sort of almost like a
lamb just ten what five like a laughing
going to psychotic okay all right I'll
get elated was it a zombie prostitute
what the hell is wrong with everyone
great yeah those are great sorry here
yeah oh thank you oh you saying that you
are you are way more energetic and
animated the crostata loca never once
the other saying done what you need to
do is also add added bits of like fake
fake cries of pea ah yeah that was that
uh uh every once in a while when I do
these if there's something it's like I'm
not sure and though I'm editing am like
yeah I should talk about that I quickly
dubbed so I was thinking about something
it's like you know uh who likes to cry
like she's giving birth
ah oh yeah so if I get those in there um
okay I'm sure no one misses that vector
not happening every single day yeah I
was watching that I'm like holy shit I'm
glad that didn't happen while I was
visiting you cuz I would have flipped my
shit of dust are ya like yeah this is
looking at the footage everything like
what the fuck is there Oh first thing
we're gonna do I'm gonna get you my
first we're doing a get some shots of
you playing I get the green strengthen
lose we get some shots of you Frank it's
a green screen then we're gonna do the
Indiana Jones thing okay I just stood
there but like I am a desert creature
whose are some of the big one again it
is the ladies pants just waiting for the
pivotal moment when Spoony goes all Man
of Steel and destroys necropolis instead
of trying to take the fight somewhere
else
ah and whose neck does he break
we're thinking mine but we always really
hope it's going to be done McGregor they
actually I do
we really have to be sick in your hand
yeah I guess it does help get into the
character oh yeah I'm always fighting
like dark Molly what's this hilarious
you all know what you want to do it no
it would have been much funnier if he
was humming like Doolittle fades they're
going to write new music for this one no
one peers you the rest is all VG's at
the other three solo defile yes I have
enough sigh I got this big one in the
last three moments what he does I think
it goes up in from the orchestra hits a
button in that autopilot from airplane
comes over it is an awesome thing those
of you at home put me someplace that I
would not normally look I'm in doing
here oh so pretty much but it's gonna be
is you know you're going to come out of
the house it was pretty much what you're
gonna gather you're going but then you
stop like true and then you're gonna go
this way so really all I need I need you
to soar jump like that you know shoot
like that and then I'm gonna - you that
way so I'm gonna need this and then just
be funny of sense that this footage and
this put something behind them but you
cannot you have people hmm
call it worth it right now run oh it's
all the amazing spider-man 2 fans
hey there's no escape okay ready not and
action all you have to do it is whole is
a costume okay
and I say I get very very determined
like you know you just use all types of
things I mean yeah just like let's make
a head just have that people bitching
and yeah you bitch Lee Joon and then the
pose this is my world
oh yeah okay okay ready yeah
and action good Oh some kung fu there uh
yeah I go ahead and you know I get ready
and action
so I'm trying to think so they're closer
I'll try imagine like when you when you
go up in you're in midair for a second
why trying to catch yourself edges are
linking up to look at you know like
you're feeling power you know okay ready
yeah at my baby
ready yeah and actually say to see if it
is out but in where as much as allergies
you know - oh yeah the more you can get
your legs out the where looks like
you're more frequent oh yes absolutely
there's a mess one motion one cat
spider-man porch right over there
the car feels spider-man fall down
ah yes me it's my friend friend
spider-man is dead yeah again like like
it's and all just everything is wrong no
I still like through yes please
no it's not no way no I've seen three
twice I see the third time I'm afraid my
brain man blow this it has lasting
effect remember we said fine yeah okay
Oh blood or can be I'm gonna be in it
- Roger secrets I love these crimes
look at the other way around you can see
the price tag on already
yes Turks will probably how much it cost
all right so hotshot right yeah how do
you want him Center yes all right so so
if we come in about here yeah and start
doing this you can see this right it is
mildly annoyed kingdom offense
yeah I mean you can see us okay right
yeah okay
quiet on the set shut that guys quiet on
the side difficulty gonna do alright
pretty mug
yeah pretty rough yep and action
I'm still in the forbidden treasure
oh I'm coming wet I fell Malcolm would
be able to accurate despite along the
dark reveal over in again yes so live
urban treasure half a sailfin you
asshole informant hi
ready mother yeah happy about Scofield
got ready and oh and Louis see if you
can face the glass oh you don't see any
letters yeah that's like a do ya gonna
do hey pretty mug wrap yeah and action
I found this picture okay okay thanks
likewise I found this picture is given
as I said White Castle many many moons
ago the ed Glaeser is like eating a
chicken ring or something like that is
weirdest look at my face as he's eating
this job like was that when you
discovered the dusseldorf
the Dusseldorf mustard and the bones in
my chicken wing oh that's where the
waiver is bad
their own marrow they're called flavor
crystals still won't change a thing it
just makes it even more you yeah I know
it's so natural at least I guess I just
really awesome crunch the chicken wing
comes from it comes from the rings up
the only ring shaped part that's why the
day after wife is she conscious there's
the problem they didn't white correctly
oh oh I walked into the Big O my fur was
like that was like a very bad like
couple of years because it was like yeah
which came out first 5 min 3 or X 3
thanks they did come out to Xavier it is
a weird was it the same you don't it's
me yes sure tell me how great that was
and I'm like are you out of your fucking
mind about whatever then he takes you to
spider-man 3 and declares that the best
spider-man movie ever ever yeah and know
how I said it fast he's like let's go to
the first two were like nothing happens
like it's the best I remember we
probably yeah cuz I'm just like oh well
dunk says it's the best spider-man he's
gotta be really good I like walk out and
I turned around like I am never
x3 and spider-man 3 the best of both
series like we're done or never has
shown the best you totally no no no no
my 3 but you said that spider-man 3 was
the best no III sir your exact word I
said look we the these others partner
movies were big hits everybody loves
some clearly we've all accepted stupid
so I accepted stupid and once you accept
stupid spider-man 3 is great no words or
egos like actually I think it's the best
of them no I wasn't it did us on my
favorite scenes like say they coming
alive is awesome you know when one says
a scene no know what Larry Franco comes
down and fights and they find there that
was awesome like there's a lot of
awesome cool scenes of it I'm sure in
chairman of the convincing and whatnot
hearing Joe day and my favorite scenes
will immunity him dancing yes
you know I actually I didn't like
spider-man 3 but I honestly didn't mind
that whole sequence right cuz like he'll
you know here's here's why because it
was like at least he had the least Tobey
Maguire had a personality in those
scenes
what happened douchey but at least it
was a personality it's rare to get into
a movie by yourself those it happens
just quite a bit really well I got ready
night should I since we're there like
every week even for that that was in the
morning
legends of Oz was like 10:00 in the
morning I've been to a bunch of crap
movies it's always like one person there
they hated by yourself though it least
happens to us every couple of oh hey
little boy like Wizard of Oz who you
love's young eunuch bow but yeah there's
I've been doing a shit load of crappy
movies there's always one of the person
they're bullying in my life been to two
movies or completely empty which one one
was fanboys hahaha
that didn't even come to Springfield
yeah ii was OG loves if you went to go
see with us because Oogie
no you went to go see the name alone
your sells itself did you did they get
like did the people return your tickets
give you a weird look like they did oh
yeah
oh no no with us like cheated we went in
and we spoke a little before we went in
so so we walk in and I'm like three four
dress like this
Bri for who he loves and the guys like
kind of laughing at us and then the
manager like slowly turns it gives us
this weird low no she didn't recognize
this or anything this was at a
completely denominator than we usually
go to um she just heard around to give
us up on your look I'm like no no no
it's we're gonna we got a pedophile
again yeah that's the one she gave us
like no no it's for a website and she
believed she was like what can okay but
she was like you guys want some magic
wands and we're like yeah no stick magic
wands and she broke his halfway through
the movie because there was a really
silly fucking joke like Cloris Leachman
lives in this teapot that's in the
middle of a tree in real life like so so
like one person says they were like
that's a nice teapot and Cloris Leachman
goes it's not a teapot that's my tree
pot and shake is just a glowing liquid
it just splashed all over dey'd it's
like Oh burn to skin like
or anything we'll be going huh we're
sitting there like oh my god there was a
talking Accuplacer named Jay Edgar yes
oh just different one place of Mexican
yeah who only speaks by hitting on bond
Wow doesn't he fly in the giant sombrero
oh yeah this sounds amazing boy Chas
polmanteer he plays a guy scream guy
with obsessed with bubbles
no that was carried by Cary Elwes yeah
do you like bubbles yeah he asked them
if they like bubbles and then he thinks
I'm in the back of his semi-truck
there's a giant oh so he would heal me
oh yeah this one I'm gonna crush you
guys are so traumatic crushing my son
Jesus you guys are so traumatic
fuckin'-a is just a movie for you right
you guys are so traumatic when did they
get like what if there's no camera there
any was without a camera that would just
be fast assembly we just like go really
quiet somebody will say something really
specific and only two people come up
from our the table go under and then
they do it three times again that would
actually be really interesting yeah like
have a scene and then somehow like
digitally crop out yeah the camera Don
Johnson yeah like in the behind the
scenes Malkovich is somebody were going
to take out this
oh yeah just cut the cameras what they
do I think Brendan and maybe stand where
you took out all Rob's lines so it looks
like Jake is like haha man suddenly it
looks really crazy yeah feels great so
also very well I think it's not super
dark but because when it's army I work
in the camera yeah it's exactly my first
thought I was like you know that makes
more sense
banana khun's follow the dark took my
Anakin you are the Jedi whose name's
first that is closest I think he needs
more jaeger eger this room yeah we have
ice ice one your Jacob this way if you
want them okay there's clam inside guys
oh yeah be inside okay okay
oh there's a sword here yes there is we
used to have that line now this is just
superconductive deed electromagnetism
yes I do okay I think if I'm an
accountant but now I gets to the mouth
that's the one thing for some reason it
forms the syllable deputy terrific but
you superconductive you mike reminded
that's the one thing I could get it at
the edges I wanted to try to save
everybody at the end but wasn't working
it's like come on superconductor
electromagnetism you said that I just
love doing like took a crab walk
tippy-toes don't joke are you Rick Lewis
oh you like this ha ha ha now this is
your birthday and the Google Analytics
do this man really love whatever I
hinted I'm gonna take off my shirt that
is true I actually I actually do need to
look at the analytics for the buffalo
bill dance because I'm guessing the
blindness rages these are gonna go to
the roof look away look away
no it's like a train wreck man I gotta
watch I know you weren't gleaming quite
as much as you were in Conan song where
you were technically like incandescent
boiled myself up for that I get some
sparkle like some glitter I think I
spoke on the ladies in and out of
reality I was a biker that was this
green screaming I know I was a bad key
yeah one confident under Konya thank
boroughs oh yeah that was it okay McGraw
girl I know we guys do merit nobody I do
Berta and when it finally came out of
like what the hell was that
ha ha ha ha ha I love the pictures of
one guru of like the alien creature ha
ha that's moody was like really wispy
thin are I said I didn't care you yeah I
don't know better the DVD but it's like
yeah there's always like one or two and
without in particularly gym like you
would have some effects I'm like oh my
god that's ingenious that's incredible
not that you have a different job uh and
then ourselves just like
was that five minutes you took so we're
just like ingenious beyond what I could
imagine and others were just so like hey
so let's not waste any time
this is wait a minute Critic we need to
address the elephant in the room here
which is him what do I do you know
exactly what you did you know what
happened a few years ago the drama you
caused all the pain and suffering
created around you oh god damn it's
booty roll a clip who are you talking to
you never went to Castleton okay I got
bad grades I dropped out okay this is
blundering do that one bit again
understand I just say I dropped out yeah
I'd say like really I'm really having it
affect you like okay okay oh good if
you're not I'm gonna make sure I have
that I got in my head again the rage
yeah okay all right guys ready ready and
so let's not waste any time
sorry liked it so let's not waste any
time
this is a diacritic oh we have something
we have to address first the elephant in
the room which of course is him I do
hope you know exactly what you did it
happened a few years ago the drama that
was caused everything that happened on
Twitter on Facebook and everything like
that
the betrayal of everything that we stand
for roll a clip you never went to
Castleton I dropped out okay this is
fluttering I was majoring in women's
studies
okay okay beautiful who is actually
doing this here we go
ah looks like I'm gonna be doing it okay
you'll be fine you're both just like
some sofas ah we will do it to you
where's your glasses we were going
around we would definitely fuck it up to
meet Rosie we have to time it perfectly
so I'm gonna be like a melted yeah doing
every bit so on that that's one it it's
gonna flop into his loud ear I know what
you should do is you don't know this
below awesome okay so on that that's
when it goes okay guys ready
so I'll get a mug look evil and stuff in
it wait I don't remember that and then
pop pop yeah yeah I'm practice take
first I'm not gonna like do the pie in
your face I'm gonna like lift it just so
I know where I'm going fine yes just so
yeah I don't remember that and then yeah
just boom like that yeah yeah the
straight up like that
Jumanji go Hank get behind the camera
there in fact why don't you watch it the
more I think of happen all these cameras
on all right this one moment waiting so
long for this
okay alright mine on the set without a
shot yep alright ready and here we go
this practice take first Oh
we're practicing yes because I would
love I'm not gonna dump it in your face
betting to make sure I'm like I'm like
moving with her okay yeah are we hitting
him with the pie this time not this not
this time
okay well then this is the practice okay
wait a minute I don't remember doing
that okay yeah yeah alright and I'm
going to look for a bit before I forget
right
we did it oh we're never doing that
great yeah somebody go ahead and take
that away from me just add it somewhere
I'm gonna did splatter on me okay yeah
go ahead
little dots I think of it yeah you're
fine
yeah I got like 50 of these now this is
why I have you out there like a
superhero closet of Batman oh why I
wanted a new one new outfit you want to
get in there yeah yeah did you want your
glasses down like that cuz when you get
on the way yeah no I'll pull it down
like this alright okay ready - yep Oh
keep I'm gonna rise again Rashad so I'll
stand up again like right here and then
I get once you stand up but I know
you're already in the shop oh good night
you're both here all right framed okay
yep good all right
hey Jim roll you know I lose hmm and
action
like I said critic once the stooge
always a stooge - I'm gonna - you Craig
I'm a manager you don't have to okay get
this off me and it tastes good actually
yeah it's do hmm a dairy-free cretin I
think it's really good yeah oh yeah we
should clean the church thank you
splotches all around here again don't be
wearing the vest during dinner what we
might be able to clean it up
you're really good my mind is buzzing
with inappropriate humor
I shall remain conserved
I have the dirtiest mind of all cream
pie
to the face oh my that is the crowning
moment of my career as a critic it used
to be and be getting to be the cinema
snob for a day now my crowning
achievement is hitting the nostalgia
critic in the face with a pie Thanks
hey that will come out right
oh yeah even any of them it didn't I
have the reason one of the reasons why I
swapped out with my old outfit was I
would have like five or six pairs
because I don't have spares with you
ah nice it's a nice vest yes but I like
supposed to be like a wedding tie invest